MAKE IT RIGHT?
>> Tucker: I TOTALLY AGREE.
>> WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
WE ARE 92 DAYS UNTIL THIS
ELECTION WHERE YOU ARE THE
ULTIMATE JURY AND TONIGHT THE
CONSPIRACY THEORIST ON THE LEFT,
YOU KNOW THE ONES THAT SOLD YOU
THE RUSSIAN HOAX, THE
IMPEACHMENT HOAX, ALL OF THEM
ARE BACK IN FULL GEAR.
HITLER COMPARISONS.
BIZARRE FANTASIES ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP GETTING FORCIBLY
REMOVED FROM OFFICE IN THE
STRAINED DRAMATIC ANALOGY FROM
HUMPTY DUMPTY ON FAKE NEWS CNN.
OFF THE RAILS TOTAL PSYCHOSIS
BUT SADLY PREDICABLE.
WE ARE GOING TO SHOW YOU THE
WORST OF THE WORST AND WE HAVE A
SPECIAL "HANNITY" INVESTIGATION.
BIDEN’S 51 YEARS OF PUBLIC LIFE,
MANY ARE WONDERING OKAY, WHAT
SPECIFICALLY IS HE GOING TO
ACCOMPLISH IN OVER FIVE DECADES
IN THE SWAMP?
OUR SPECIAL 2020 CORRESPONDENT
LAWRENCE JONES HIT THE STREETS
OF NEW YORK TO FIND OUT IF
ANYONE COULD NAME A SINGLE
ACCOMPLISHMENT.
THIS SHOULD BE ENTERTAINING.
LAWRENCE WILL BRING US AN
EXCLUSIVE INVESTIGATION INTO THE
MASSIVE CRIME WAVE IN
DE BLASIO’S NEW YORK WITH
1 BILLION IN CUTS FOR THE NYPD.
WE ARE GOING TO SHOW YOU EXACTLY
WHAT DEFUNDING THE POLICE LOOK
LIKE.
SPOILER ALERT.
THINK WAR ZONE.
FIRST TONIGHT WE START WITH
DEMOCRATIC MAJORITY WHIP JAMES
CLYBURN.
HE IS IN LEADERSHIP.
THIRD-HIGHEST RANKING DEMOCRAT
IN THE HOUSE, A CLOSED BIDEN
ALLY.
THIS WEEKEND HE CONTINUED TO
FLOAT YET MORE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, KIND OF A TINFOIL HAT
CONSPIRACY THEORY ABOUT TRUMP,
POLLUTANT, NAZI GERMANY,
MUSSOLINI, AND FASCISM.
LAST WEEK HE WAS COMPARING
TRUMP, USING WHATEVER HE AND
PELOSI SAID, GESTAPO TACTICS AND
OTHER CRAZY STUFF.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DO YOU REALLY THINK
DONALD TRUMP IS COMPARABLE TO
ADOLF HITLER?
>> TWO AND A HALF MAYBE THREE
YEARS AGO.
THE STATE OF THE UNION.
I FELT VERY STRONGLY THAT THIS
MAN HAS TAKEN ON A STRONG-ARM
TACTIC.
I FEEL VERY STRONGLY THAT HE IS
MUSSOLINI, PUTIN IS HITLER.
I BELIEVE VERY STRONGLY, THE
IDEA ABOUT THIS, THE PEACEFUL
TRANSFER OF POWER.
I BELIEVE THAT HE PLANS TO
INSTALL HIMSELF IN SOME KIND OF
EMERGENCY WAY TO CONTINUE TO
HOLD ON TO OFFICE.
BETWEEN NANCY AND I’LL ADJUST,
FASCIST ANALOGIES.
WHAT YOU HEARD IS DELUSIONAL BUT
IT’S THE CURRENT FAVORITE HOAX
OF THE RADICAL LEFT.
THE SAME CAST OF DEMOCRATIC
EXTREMISTS, THE SAME LYING MOB
IN THE MEDIA THAT BROUGHT YOU
THE FAILED RUSSIA CONSPIRACY
THEORY HOAX AND AND THE FAILED
UKRAINE HOAX.
THEY NOW WANT YOU TO BELIEVE
THAT DONALD TRUMP IS GOING TO
REFUSE TO LEAVE OFFICE AND
BECOME A DICTATOR.
FAKE NEWS CNN APRIL RYAN EVEN
OPENLY FANTASIZING ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT GETTING PULLED OUT OF
THE OVAL OFFICE BY ARMED FORCES.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THERE’S GOING TO BE A SPLIT
SCREEN ON JANUARY 20TH, 2021.
IF JOE BIDEN IS GOING TO BE THE
46TH PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, YOU WILL HAVE HIM
BEING INAUGURATED AND WATCHING
POLICE AND ARMED FORCES TRYING
TO PULL DONALD TRUMP OUT OF THE
WHITE HOUSE.
I CANNOT WAIT FOR THAT SPLIT
SCREEN.
>> Sean: THIS IS THE
ARRANGEMENT SADLY PREDICTABLE
BEHAVIOR.
WE SEE IT EVERY TWO YEARS AND
EVERY FOUR YEARS, AND AS WE NOW
MARCH CLOSER TO THE ELECTION,
THE THREE-MONTH MARK, THE SMEAR
MACHINE IS ONLY GOING TO GET
WORSE.
PREPARE YOURSELF FOR THE
GREATEST INSANITY, EMOTIONAL
ROLLER COASTER, WELL, YOU
PROBABLY NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
WHAT DO THEY DO?
THEY DIVIDE THE COUNTRY, OLD,
YOUNG, RICH, POOR.
THEY USE RACIAL IDENTITY
POLITICS.
THEY HAVE BIZARRE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES.
THEY ARE EVEN GETTING MORE
BIZARRE.
ON SUNDAY, PROFESSIONAL FOX
SOCCER, WE CALL HIM
AFFECTIONATELY.
EMPTY, COMPARING THE PRESIDENT
TO A DRIVER WHO IS TRYING TO
CRASH HIS CAR INTENTIONALLY.
IN HUMPTY AS WELL DRAMATIC
SCENARIO, THE CAR REPRESENTS OUR
ARE A DEMOCRATIC REPUBLIC, IF WE
CAN KEEP IT, AS BEN FRANKLIN
ONCE WARNED.
DEMOCRAT JAMIE RASKIN ACCUSE THE
PRESIDENT OF TURNING THE G.O.P.
INTO A RELIGIOUS CULT.
TONIGHT THIS KIND OF EXTREME
RHETORIC IS NOT JUST TRUMP
DERANGEMENT SYNDROME.
IT IS AN INTENTIONAL DISTRACTION
COUPLED WITH DERANGEMENT AND
REAL PSYCHOSIS TO KEEP YOUR
ATTENTION AWAY FROM ALL THINGS,
YEAH, THE EVER CORRUPT CONFUSED
AND SLOW JOE BIDEN.
IT’S ALSO THAT THE DEMOCRATS AND
THEIR STATE RUN SOCIALIST TV
ALLIES, THEY ARE ACTUALLY SCARED
TO DEATH THAT YOU, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, WILL REELECT
DONALD TRUMP AS THE 45TH
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
FOR THE SAKE OF OUR KIDS AND
GRANDKIDS, AND THE WORLD, I PRAY
WE DO.
THEY KNOW THAT JOE IS WEAK.
THEY KNOW HE’S CORRUPT.
THEY KNOW HIS TRACK RECORD IS
PATHETIC.
HE’S ONE OF THE WORST
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES IN
HISTORY.
HE IS HIDING BECAUSE OF IT.
AND PELOSI, SCHUMER, BOLSHEVIK
BURNING, AOC’S POLICIES, IF THEY
ARE IMPLEMENTED, THEY WILL
DESTROY WHAT IS THE GREATEST
COUNTRY GOD HAS GIVEN MAN AND
PUT THE WORLD IN GREAT PERIL.
WITHOUT US LEAVING COME OF THE
WORLD IS IN DEEP TROUBLE WHICH
BRINGS US TO AN IMPORTANT
"HANNITY" HISTORY LESSON.
51 YEARS OF PUBLIC LIFE, OKAY,
ASK YOURSELF AT HOME.
WHAT HAS JOE BIDEN ACCOMPLISHED?
I CAN TELL YOU WHAT CHILD HAS
ACCOMPLISHED IN LESS THAN FOUR.
LET’S START WITH BIDEN’S UNCANNY
KNACK FOR ALWAYS MAKING THE
WRONG DECISION.
FOR EXAMPLE, BIDEN OPPOSED THE
20112011 NAVY SEAL RAID THAT KIL
BIN LADEN.
BIDEN ALSO SPOKE OUT AGAINST A
SUCCESSFUL TROOP SURGE IN 2007
AND BIDEN WAS AN ENTHUSIASTIC
SUPPORTER OF OBAMA’S STRATEGY TO
BAND IN THE MIDDLE EAST WHICH
LEFT MASSIVE VACUUM FILLED BY
ISIS.
OH, YEAH, AND HE PUSHED THE BIG
LIE, KEEP YOUR DOCTOR, PLAN AND
SAVE MONEY.
MILLIONS LOST HER DOCTORS, THEIR
PLANS, WE ARE ALL PAINT 200%
MORE.
HE VOTED FOR THE WAR IN IRAQ AND
NOW HE SAYS IT WAS A MISTAKE.
BY ANOTHER WRONG SIDE OF RACIAL
INTEGRATION.
LET’S GO TO NBC NEWS, SHALL WE?
HE LED THE CHARGE ON AN ISSUE
THAT KEPT BLACK STUDENTS AWAY
FROM THE CLASSROOMS OF WHITE
STUDENTS.
AS BIDEN ONCE SAID, HE DID NOT
WANT HIS CHILDREN TO GROW UP IN
A RACIAL JUNGLE.
SENATOR KAMALA HARRIS, NOY FRONT
RUNNER WE HEAR, WHO KNOWS, MAYBE
AHEAD FAKE FOR THE VIP
STAKES BUT IF YOU WANT TO GO SHE
HAD THIS TO SAY ABOUT
BIDEN’S ANTI-INTEGRATION
EFFORTS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I ALSO BELIEVE, AND IT’S
PERSONAL AND IT WAS HURTFUL.
TO HEAR YOU TALK ABOUT THE
REPUTATION OF TWO UNITED STATES
SENATORS WHO BUILT THEIR
REPUTATIONS AND CAREER ON THE
SEGREGATION OF RACE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
AND IT WAS NOT ONLY THAT BUT YOU
ALSO WORKED WITH THEM TO OPPOSE
BUSING.
AND THERE WAS A LITTLE GIRL IN
CALIFORNIA WHO WAS PART OF THE
SECOND CLASS TO INTEGRATE HER
PUBLIC SCHOOL.
AND SHE WAS ASKED TO SCHOOL
EVERY DAY.
IN THAT LITTLE GIRL WAS MEAN.
>> Sean: WHY DOESN’T JOE BIDEN
LOOK SOMEONE IN THE I LISTEN TO
WHAT THEY HAVE TO SAY.
KAMALA WANTS TO BE BIDEN’S
RUNNING MATE, PRETTY PATHETIC
AND BY THE WAY BIDEN’S HORRIFIC
TRACK RECORD DOESN’T END THERE.
A FEW YEARS AGO DURING THE
BARACK AND JOE DAYS, THERE IT
ADMINISTRATION, BIDEN WAS A
POINT PERSON FOR UKRAINE U.S.
RELATIONS AND DURING THAT TIME
WE ALREADY KNOW HE ALLOWED PUTIN
TO STEAL CRIMEA ALL WHILE ZERO
EXPERIENCE SON, WELL, HUNTER GOT
FILTHY RICH THANKS TO THE
SKETCHY DEAL WITH THE
PRO-RUSSIAN ENERGY COMPANY ALL
WHILE LEVERAGING A BILLION
DOLLARS OF YOUR MONEY.
QUID PRO QUO JOE, ZERO
EXPERIENCE HUNTER.
BIDEN ALSO WAS IN CHARGE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION IS TRYING TO
POLICY AND FOR YEARS JOE, WELL,
HE DID HIS BEST TO COZY UP TO
THE COUNTRY’S RULING COMMUNIST
PARTY.
ALL WHILE AGAIN HUNTER, WELL, HE
STRUCK ANOTHER LUCRATIVE
DEAL, THIS TIME WITH THE BANK OF
CHINA.
NO EXPERIENCE ANYONE CAN FIND.
FLASH FORWARD TO THIS YEAR WHEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP SIGNED OFF ON
THE LIFE-SAVING TRAVEL BAN TO
AND FROM CHINA.
TEN DAYS AFTER THE FIRST
IDENTIFIED CORONAVIRUS CASE
HERE, BIDEN WAS AGAINST THE
BAND.
HE IS ONE WHO CALLED IT
HYSTERICAL XENOPHOBIA AND
FEARMONGERING.
HOW MANY THOUSANDS OF AMERICAN
LIVES WERE SAVED BY THE
PRESIDENT’S DECISION TEN DAYS
AFTER THAT FIRST CASE IN THE
U.S.?
BY THE WAY, TO DO THAT, HE WAS
ALSO BEING IMPEACHED.
JOE, WRONG AS USUAL.
IT’S A HORRIFIC TRACK RECORD.
WE SEND OUR OWN LAWRENCE JONES,
OUR 2020 CORRESPONDENT, HE WENT
OUT TO THE STREETS OF NEW YORK
TO SEE IF ANYONE COULD JUST NAME
A SINGLE POSITIVE ACHIEVEMENT
FROM BIDEN’S FIVE DECADES OF
PUBLIC LIFE.
I HAVEN’T SEEN THIS YET.
THIS IS GOING TO BE INTERESTING.
>> WHAT WOULD YOU SAY IS
JOE BIDEN’S SIGNATURE
ACCOMPLISHMENT?
>> PRESIDENT OBAMA’S RIGHT HAND.
>> WHAT IS ONE ACCOMPLISHMENT
FOR JOE BIDEN?
HE HAS BEEN IN POLITICS FOR 47
YEARS.
>> I DON’T KNOW WHAT.
HE’S A NICE MAN.
HE SMILES A LOT.
I DON’T SEE ANY KIND OF STRESS.
ANY KIND OF STRENGTH TO LEAD THE
NATION THAT IS A MESS.
I’M A DEMOCRAT.
>> BIDEN IS YOUR PERSON.
HE’S BEEN IN OFFICE FOR 47
YEARS.
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY IS HIS NUMBER
ONE ACCOMPLISHMENT?
>> BRINGS PEOPLE TOGETHER.
BETTER THAN DONALD TRUMP.
>> BIDEN IS THE DIET.
>> IS UNFORTUNATE THAT THAT’S